[音楽]
エヴァ a ご紹介にあずかりましたあの
すごい装置作ったといただいたので実はこれです
たぶんこの距離で見ていただいても普通のメガネかけているだけに見えるかと思います
これが僕のスマートフォンとずっとつながっていて僕は今15分ぐらいお話をする内容
ちゃんと集中してお話が出来たかみたいなことをデータ
鳥するデバイスをつくってこれの事業を運営している井上と申し上げます
多分所へジョセフさんが妻さっきおっしゃったそのアテンションちゃんとこう集めて
フロー体験をしていくために
じゃあこういうデータを見ていくとどういうことをちゃんと携えると人はフロー体験に
入れるかそういうことを研究
有しているものです jins meme は簡単にいうと眼の動きと瞬きと姿勢を
この普通に見えるメガネがずーっと一日中とってくれます
それを基にどれだけ今自分が集中しているかということを反転する装置です
でこの装置をですね実際事業としてやっていて今まで延べで1万人くらいのデータを
ずっと降ってきました
ああそうすると驚愕のことが分かりましてあのアン男性陸遜というですね心理学者が3
受けた効果の提唱していることでいうと人は1日4時間まで集中できると言われている
そうです
なんですが現代人は jins meme で測るとですね1日4時間以上を
定常的に集中出来てる人って
16パー子がいいのですね逆にできてない人本だけいるんです
これって何なんだろうということをデータを見るだけじゃやっぱり自分のことって
分からないのでいろんな大人と話をしていきました
そうするとみんなこぞっていうのが
ちっちゃい時って全然集中何かも時間を忘れてまで集中する時ってあったなと
最近大人になってから時間忘れるほど夢中になったことってありますかと
意外とないなとでここで急にですね自慢が入ります
完全にあの私人生の唯一の自慢なんですけど
小学校の時にですねあの算数オリンピックというなんかちょっと天才児が集まりそうな
を癖来たかで一応アジアで4位をとったんですね
なんでこの時は何かに夢中にするつ
なる力がむちゃくちゃってたぶんすごい集中できてたんです
これが大人になった僕がどうなったかちょっとのちほど付見せしますねってちょっと
地墨6の話に戻すと
この jins meme で測ると例えば一つこんなことがわかります
ちょっと皆さんご自身のことだと思って考えてみてください
これうちの会社でほぼ同じワークスタイルの4人が
どうもずっと jins meme をかけて集中しているかというのは取っています
これ全部横軸時間軸になっていてこれ見るとですね
i さんはこれ午前中しか集中してないです
k さんは号から歯が伸びて来ないですね
この人たちが
同じ時間に集まって仕事してたんです
もう学校には8時半に集められ会社には9時に集められて仕事をしてるんですね
人ってあの遺伝子学的にもうあの時計時計遺伝子というのが見つかっていて生まれ持っ
て朝型か夜型か決まっているそうです
それなのに僕らは同じ時間にパフォーマンスを出そうとして無理してたりするんですね
でこれってどういうことを僕はじゃあ jins meme を通じてこのメガネを
通じてやりたいと思っているかって話をすると
アスリートの世界アスリートってすごく集中力があってパフォーマンスに対してすごく
まあ向き合っているところですね彼らじゃーなんて向き合えるかというと例えば
スプリント競技陸上競技で100メートル走を走る人にとっては1日10回ぐらい
500メートル走走ると全部
これが何個目が良かったかってことをこの人教えてくれるはずなんですね
ストップウォッチがあります
4回目はどういう心持ちでスタートラインに立ってどんな蹴り足にしたら良かったか
悪かったかこれが分かるんです
だけど僕らオフィスワーカーは会社にいて普通に酢生活をして
じゃあ帰り際に例えば上司とか新メンバーに共同だったって聞かれても
まあまあみたいなことしか言えないよねなんなのでパフォーマンスを測ることができ
ないからなんか高めるきっかけがないのかなというふうに思っています
これが jins meme のお話ですでちょっと戻ってですねぼく
多分天才児っぽく質問数集中できてたはずの僕が今大人になるとどうなったかです
ああああああ
私はですね普段生活しているオフィスがこちらですこれもちょっと
結構いいいい感じの人だと思うんですね
なんですけどデータ取ると恐ろしいことが分かりました
いろんな場所で僕は働いているんですけどどこの場所が集中するかってとっていくと
横木もともと頭の悪最強説をずーっととないですね
ジュノーあるで一番集中できるなと思っていました
でそうしたら土曜の昼の公演のほうが集中できました
これ自体はですね人によって違うのであまり参考にしないでください
ください6割ぐらいの人は静かな図書館のほうが集中していいたようです
なんですが僕個人さらに1万人のデータをずっと見てきたら僕らはですね
所属してるオフィスが一番集中してないです恐ろしいぐらい集中
てないんです
何でなんでしょうね全然種大人になってから集中してないんです
これなんてか結論申し上げます
ある研究では人って何か一つのことに
まあ店焼酎注意を向けて深い集中状態に入るまでに平均で23分かかるんです
23分かけないと僕らは深い集中状態に入っていかないですね
それなのに僕らは現代人は11分に1回は話しかけられるか見なきゃいけないメールが
ちょっとなっているんです
ってこれ5年前のデータなので今ってもスラックとかラインとかなりまくるんでこの
11分でもっと
神とわかってるはずなんですねそれだけ深い集中に入るためにはあの23分数なのに
邪魔ばっかりされているんです
もうご唱和くださいのレベルんですけどもうちょっといいですかの欧州なんですね
オフィス行くともうちょっといいですかちょっといいですかをやり続けるんで僕30分
のデータをずっといつもとっていると平均で4回
ちょっといい
ですがやられていますそれだけ深い集中をと取るようにはコミュニケーション優先し
すぎてですね
で者集中測ってみると大人が全然集中していないという事実に対してじゃあそもそも
集中なんかしなきゃいけないのかって議論が絶対に必要だと思います
ここでいろんな経営学の先生とか心理学の先生ま脳神経科学の先生と話をしていたです
ねよく
系
額の中でイノベーションの研究をされている系学者がこぞって最近
提唱するお話なんですが僚機期の経営と言われます
右利きと左利きこの右乳後の進化というものと左日の知の探索
この2つを同時に両方持っていないし
組織個人はイノベーションが起こせないそうです
何か新しいものを生むためには簡単に言うともうちょっと明るめな言葉で難しいので
簡単に言うとこうワーキングスペースという言葉に象徴される好惡コミュニケーション
ですコミュニケーションと個人の集中の両方が高い状態にないと僕らイノベーションが
起こせない
いいのに先ほど申し上げました
こうワークのことを優先しすぎているオフィスがに僕らはいてずーっと
コミュニケーションは勝手ですねちょっといいですかなお城している
でさらにいつだってこれがなるんで
て
例えば飛行機に乗ったっても今 wi-fi つながるぐらいなので
本質的に1人になる時間がないはずなんです
なので deeps インクするということが非常に足りない環境になってきていると
いうのが僕らがある状況かなというふうに思います
もうちょっといいですかの応酬だなと思っています
なのでこうワークばっかしていてディープスイングができないでもう一つ日本語で独走
という言葉を創造してやっぱり書いてみますけど見ていただくとやっぱり日本人の昔の
人はしっかりしてですね独走ての一人で作ると書くんです
なんで何か独創的なアイデアを
作るためには1人になって深い深い集中状態を作らないと
やっぱりアイディアが出てこないですねなんで新しいものって絶対にこれが必要だなと
いうふうに思っています
で本日あのテッドさんに読んでいただいて僕もこの日ガーさん明日というテーマを
いただいて何をお話ししたいかって言うとですね
今お話ししている通り今この20年くらい30年くらいで ict の技術がガンガン
ガンガン進歩して
情報収集するということは本当に簡単になって便利になってきています
でこれ自体も絶対に便利だから正しいんですが
便利だけど常に常に外の情報から脅かさで続けているというのが今の僕らの状況だと
いうふうに思います
それに対してこういう家がは自分の状態を知ることができれば自分にとって本当に大事
な時間だったり大事な
まあそのテーマっていうのを絞り込んでそこに向き合うようなまぁ右が左がですね左側
のテクノロジーが高まってきたからこそ新しいとか
ノロジーでこれを支えていきたいなというふうに私どもは思っておりますので
jins meme というこのデータ集中のデータを基にその本当に集中できる環境
というのは僕らは研究をしています
こんな場所ですねこんな場所を作って展開をしています
で今日ちょっと持って帰っていただきたいのがじゃあどうやったら明日から集中できる
かということを
ちょっと覚えて帰ってください置き換え言った3つありますちょっと戻してください
えっと要素と構造と準備というものです
ええええええ
要素というのが一番簡単なのでいいますと例えば僕お昼ご飯にですね丼も勝っ込んだり
すると
2時4時の集中的活用中ですってこれなんでかっていうと血糖値が上がり過ぎちゃうと
上がった時30分だけは集中できるんですけど落ち始めると全然集中できないんですね
なんでどうやったら人が集中できるかという要素をご紹介します
ちょっとこれ全部覚えられるわけないですけど僕らがずーっと実験を繰り返すと集中
できている時とできてない時で
因子が25種類ありましたさっきのお昼ごはんの食べ方その一つですその25種類の方
方をどっちをやると本当に人は集中できるかということがこんな簡易デバイスがある
からずっと研究できるんですね
なんでそのデータの中で誰にとってもそれなりに集中できるという要素を引っ張り出し
て
日本の中央官庁と一緒にですねその効果が本当にあるのかっていう研究をした結果が
こちらになります
先ほどの梅笹の話にもあったかと思うんですがやっぱり僕ら人工物に囲まれすぎてるん
で出来る限り自然の環境に戻してあげる
ストレスとリラックスの状態をちゃんといいバランスにしてあげるというのが効果的
でした
こんなことを要素として返球しておりますで
気が構造です要素構造その2個目になります
構想としてはですね集中するためにはすごく簡単な言葉で言うと
緊張とリラックスという相反する状態を同時に保持している人があります緊張感な奴
って絶対集中しないです1年後にレポートを出せと言われて羞恥
できる人見たことないんで緊張から人なんですだけどリラックスもできてないと続か
ないんで僕だってだいたいまあ6時間とか8時間仕事をすることが多いので緊張感と
リラックスをちゃんと同時に保持する
このためにどうするかというとよく言われるアスリートの世界でよるルーティーンです
緊張とリラックスは順番があります
僕らの研究結果で作った新クラブという所ではまず
真っ暗な道を25メートル歩きます
緊張感を先に高めるですね緊張を高めてからパットリラック数
この順番がちゃんとできていると
人って集中に入りやすいですなのでこの環境を作るのは難しいですが緊張とリラックス
簡単です
力を入れてからパッと話せば緊張からリラックスになるんで
何かに集中したいと思ったらこの緊張からリラックスというこの構造流れというのを
覚えておいてください
これが二つ目です
てこの今度は集中できる場所を曲作って運営してるんだし僕自身がデータ3でも全然
集中が上がってこない時期があったんですね
これ何でだろうというふうに考えた時に準備という言葉にたどり着きました今なにかと
いうとですね
jins meme で測ってもう一つ置き買ったのが
戸先に何をするか
何分でやるかって決めてる人と何となく測定をしている人
これは全然集中の
バランスが違いました人って何をこの時間にするかって決めてるだけで集中が上がるん
ですね
逆のこと言うと皆さんちょっとドキっとしていただきたいんですけど皆さん
スケジュール見てください
そうすると皆さんのスケジュールって絶対海自から埋まっていると思うんです
しょうがないんですね会議し
ちょっと人を抑えなきゃいけないんで変数が多い胎児という好枠からスケジュールって
埋まっていくんです
で
会議が埋まった後のスケジュールの会議が入ってない子の合間の時間のことをみんな
指さして何て言いますか
空いてるって言うんですね
野洲市これ開いてないですこうワークとコミュニケーションと集中は同等に大事なのに
僕らは会議は予約するのに集中は予約しないんですね
ちゃんと集中を予約して自分の時間を決める
自分の時間を確保するということが見つめ大事になっていきますので明日から集中し
たいと思ったらこの要素をちゃんと自然に近づけ
ルーティーンを用いで周知を予約するという
ちゃんとこういう生き方をしていただきたいなというふうに思っています
そういうデータを基にこう研究を繰り返し今の情報が氾濫して集中できない僕らをなん
とかサポートしたいなというふうに思って今後いろいろ授業展開をしていきますで最後
にですねちょっと
ほとんど意識高い奴だなっていうちょっとことを言うんですけど
50,000時間今何の数字か
わかるわけないですねそう
これ何かというとですね最初に申し上げましたアンダーズエリクソンが入ってたのは1
日ひとは4時間しか集中できないんです
そうすると1ヶ月頑張って100時間がですね1年間頑張って1000時間が限界なん
です
人生100年世代だってライフシフトしたって言ったって
100年の家何かの仕事に打ち込むのってたぶん50年が限界だろうとそうすると僕
らって人生でコーヒー5万時間しか集中できるリソース持ってないんです
例えば異常な議論があるんですけど1万時間の法則と言い方があります
何か一つのカテゴリーの中で1万時間かけないと人ってそのカテゴリーのことを極め
られないと言われていますそうすると5万時間しか持っていない僕らはどんなにうまく
設計士
でも人生で5個しか極められないんですね
なんでデータ測ってみると回り回って結構こういうことに辿り着いたっていうのが結構
象徴的だなと思うんですが
5分の1しか1/5人生で5個しかできないんだったら今目の前のものを
無駄なものに集中してちゃ絶対ダメで本当に自分の人生の1/5かけていいと思うもの
を見つける
これが集中するための極意だと思っています
なので僕らはこういうデータをもとに研究をずっと繰り返しつつ
でこういうリバーライフという言葉を作ったんですが自分の人生にちゃんとし
集中できるようなそんな生き方をサポートできればと思って色々
続けていきますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]